[موسيقى]
أنا دكتور سانجاي غوبتا مضيفًا
لبودكاست مطاردة الحياة على قناة سي إن إن ،
كما تعلم ، كنا جميعًا نقف
في طابور في متجر البقالة الذي يتم
تعليقه عند الاتصال بشركة بطاقة الائتمان الخاصة بك
أو العد التنازلي لعطلة
تنتظرها  مثل التعذيب
سواء أحببته أم لا تنتظره هو
جزء من حياتنا اليومية والتوتر الناجم
عنه يمكن أن يكون في الواقع ضارًا بصحتنا ،
فكيف نتعلم ممارسة المزيد من
الصبر جيدًا إحدى الطرق هي إلهاء
نفسك وهذا يتيح لك إنشاء
علم النفس  البروفيسور كيت سويني
تسمي حالة التدفق وتقول بمجرد الانخراط
في نشاط آخر سواء كان
شيئًا مثل اللغز أو حتى
البستنة ، فإنه يقلل من قدرتك على
التفكير في أي شيء باستثناء ما
تفعله إذا كنت قد ذهبت إلى عالم ديزني.
اعلم أنهم الأساتذة
في هذه التقنية ، فهم يبذلون
جهودًا متقنة لإلهاء الزائرين
عن حقيقة أنهم ينتظرون
لساعات في الطابور ،
على سبيل المثال إذا ذهبت إلى
جبل الفضاء إذا كان لديك تطبيق loa  استنتاج
أنه سيسمح لك ببناء
سفينة فضاء وبمجرد أن يتم بناء سفينة الفضاء الخاصة بك ،
عليك أن تتسابق مع
أشخاص آخرين في طابور الانتظار من حولك
لفترات أطول من الانتظار مثل دعنا
نقول لنتائج اختبار طبي كبير
لا تفعله '  لا تريد أن
تشعر وكأنك تؤجل حياتك ، لذا
يقترح سويني التخطيط مسبقًا
إذا كنت تستعد للنتيجة المحتملة ،
يمكن أن يعطيك هذا إحساسًا
بالسيطرة بدلاً من الشعور
وكأنك تنتظر أخبارًا سيئة